Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, my Bonus Video
this week will be all about Braavos.
The episode 6 teaser had a bunch of scenes
at the Iron Bank, so I thought this would
be the perfect time to talk about it.
We’re really just seeing the city for the
first time so what I’m going to do is talk
a little bit about where it is in relation
to Meereen and Slaver’s Bay, what the big
groups are and the Iron Bank’s role on the
show.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do bonus videos for Game of Thrones every
week in addition to reviews of the episodes
and Q&As.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
feel free to leave me suggestions for videos
to do.
So first order of business.
Because some of you may have read the books,
please try to be careful about posting spoilers
in the comments, or at least use spoiler tags.
We’re not really sure how much the show
is going to change about what goes on in Braavos,
so best to play it safe.
Whenever I post my review I’ll talk about
what those big changes are.
So WTF is Braavos?
If you saw the trailers, then this image here.
It’s the Titan of Braavos.
It’s one of the 9 wonders of man.
It’s inspired by the Colossus of Rhodes
for any history buffs.
But the Titan is the most visible symbol of
the city.
It’s even stamped on Braavosi coins.
And passing beneath the Titan is the only
way for ships to enter the port.
Braavos itself is the most powerful of the
Free Cities.
It’s located in a lagoon way up North on
the tip of the eastern continent.
The city itself exists on a series of small
islands connected by bridges.
Remember how Daenerys is in Meereen right
now?
She’s way down here on the other side of
the continent.
The city formed about 500 years before Aegon’s
Landing in Westeros from people fleeing the
Valyrian Expansion.
It’s nicknamed the Bastard Son of Valyria
because the people that colonized it were
trying to hide from Valyria’s dragons.
So it wasn’t till after the doom that Braavos
started to make itself known to the rest of
the world.
It’s a port city that draws it’s wealth
from trade and shipping, and as a result it’s
one of the wealthiest cities in the world.
Thus the Iron Bank of Braavos became the most
powerful bank in the world.
The most notable locations in the city are
the Titan itself, Drowned Town which is an
area where the city has sunken into the lagoon,
The House of Black and White which is the
Temple of the Many Faced God, there are temples
to a lot of different gods that all exist
in an area called the isle of the gods.
So as you see the temple of R’hollor Melisandre’s
god is here too, there’s Purple Harbor which
is really only used by locals near the Sealord’s
palace.
He’s the ruler of Braavos.
Then there’s the Iron Bank here.
This is where the scene with Mark Gatiss in
the trailer takes place.
There’s Ragman’s Harbor, which is used
by most foreign traders visiting on business
and then the Temple of the Moonsingers, they
were actually the people that found the site
where Braavos would eventually be located
after they fled Valyria.
There’s a billion different locations so
the next time the show comes here I’ll go
into greater detail about the different locations.
The most important location for right now
is the Iron Bank.
It’s the one common denominator amongst
all the factions on the show.
You can’t win the Iron Throne without a
war or a marriage.
And both cost money.
Which as we learned from Tywin Lannister last
week, no one has.
The Tyrells are wealthy, but most of their
assets are in farmland.
So the only way to get more money is to borrow
it from the Iron Bank.
Just to give you an idea of how powerful it
is, it’s bigger than all the other banks
in the free cities combined.
It’s the biggest bank in the world.
It’s mostly known for the way it goes after
debts.
Which is funny, because up to this point on
the show we’ve heard the Lannister motto
so many times.
A Lannister always pays his debts.
The Iron Bank’s motto is “The Iron Bank
will have it’s due”.
What happens when a King or a nation borrows
money and doesn’t pay them back is the Iron
Bank will support a new King.
And
once they install said new King, that person
has to repay the original debt or the Iron
Bank will do the exact same thing and replace
them with another King.
So when you think about it, the Iron Bank
is the most powerful organization in the World.
Even the Iron Throne has to bow to them.
Which is why Stannis in the trailer almost
looks like he’s begging Mark Gatiss for
money.
The conceit being that because King Robert
borrowed so much money and never paid it back,
Stannis will probably try to convince them
to back his claim in exchange for repayment
of the debt.
I don’t know how the show is going to deal
with that plot, but I’m interested to see
what terms they set for Stannis.
And remember, if Stannis does get a loan and
doesn’t pay it back.
The Iron Bank could always turn around and
fund one of his enemies.
Needless to say, the Iron Bank controls the
flow of money and therefore it controls the
balance of war.
Based on the teaser for episode 6 it’s hard
to tell which other places we might get to
see, but her in the harbor you can see the
Sealord’s palace.
But we might get to see some waterdancers
or maybe a few easter eggs.
Remember how Arya was practicing her waterdancing
for the Hound last week.
Syrio Forel who taught her was one of the
Bravos.
Just one O in bravos.
They’re a special class of fighters that
developed the waterdancing technique and they
dress in really bright loud colors as you
can see.
The wealthy people in the city all dress in
really drab grey colors.
As you can see Mark Gatiss, wealthy banker
here.
Anyone in Braavos carrying a sword after dark
can be challenged to a duel, it doesn’t
matter who you are.
It’s just part of the culture that they
challenge each other constantly just for bragging
rights as the best fighter in the city.
So say someone like Syrio Forel probably had
to fight people every single night.
And because he lived to a pretty decent age
it meant he was a badass.
The place where most of them go to duel is
the Moon Pool here, right near the Iron Bank.
So there’s a good chance we’ll see it
in episode 6.
The city also has a really strong tradition
of Courtesans that hold a special status in
the culture.
They command extremely high prices.
So just think of the money a prince with Oberyn
Martell’s appetites would spend.
Like a kid in a candy store.
All the best whore houses are either up here
in the Purple Harbor.
Or around the Moon Pool.
Isn’t it funny that all the best sex in
the city is right next to the bank.
I guess that says something about people’s
priorities.
Sex and Money.
Seems about right.
I’m really hoping that we get to see more
of the city this season just because it’s
so much fun to talk about.
Of all the cities that the show has depicted,
I would say this is the best, with Meereen
being number 2, even though we haven’t seen
a lot of it yet.
And King’s Landing third.
Unless you count the Lands of Always Winter
we saw in episode 4.
That white walker city looked pretty sweet.
But now it’s your turn, what are you hoping
to see in Braavos this week?
I know a lot of the Doctor Who and Sherlock
fans are excited to see Mark Gatiss.
Given what we know about his character from
the books, I’m really interested to see
if he plays it more like Mycroft or if he’s
going to play it a little lighter.
He essentially has the task of showing us
what that motto means, The Iron Bank Will
Have It’s Due.
So I’m expecting a scarier version of Mycroft.
I’ll be posting my episode 6 review tonight
after it airs.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Round 6 of the giveaway will also be starting
then.
Real quick I want to say Happy Mother’s
Day to all the mom’s out there.
Even Cersei.
Right now click here to catch up on last week’s
episode and click here for my Q&A
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!